from illinois to kenosha ended up with
two protesters dead and one
injured um you indicated this was
because this
operational mistake was because facebook
had just adopted its militia policy a
week earlier
and contractors without specialized
training didn't pick up the violation
and i appreciate your frankness as to
that in your
answers to questions earlier today from
senator durbin
but your response to senator durbin
didn't mention that the event page
also violated a separate call to arms
policy
in place for over a year that
contractors aren't tasked to enforce
so i just have to ask as a follow-up why
didn't you before
and also today reference the call to
arms policy
when reviewing what went wrong in
kenosha
uh senator my understanding
is that that post did not necessarily
violate
that uh call to arms policy at the time
um the the call to arms policy is not
does not
uh prohibit anyone from saying um
you know let's let's go get our guns and
do something
uh you know for example if people are
organizing a hunting trip you
that's obviously not going to be
something that should be against the
policies
um but what we do on some of these po
on some of these policies which i think
it's it's i'm glad to get the
opportunity to address this
is some of these are context specific
and just require
a higher level of context and expertise
in the area to enforce
so we don't necessarily have um all of
the 35 000 reviewers
assess every single one of these
policies
so i can follow up in more detail if
you'd like on the call to arms policy
and the nuance there specifically
um but that's that's also uh a bit on
how we we operationalize these policies
thank you for that answer i i do want to
follow up uh because just
facially it seemed to me that this was a
violation of your own call to arms
policy
um but i i look forward to that to that
conversation
mr dorsey if i might um at a house
energy committee
hearing i think it was two years ago um
you committed
to something that i was just discussing
with mr zuckerberg
an independent civil rights audit but in
your case of twitter
and the audit released by facebook in
july has proven invaluable to bringing
sunlight
to some key areas in which facebook does
need to improve
uh will you follow through in your
commitment and commission to this
independent audit of twitter
so we work with civil rights groups um
all over the country and around the
world
to give feedback we're in constant
conversation with them
and we do believe that being more
transparent
and making our transparency report a lot
more robust which
today we still have some gaps is
important for
any entity to audit independently of us
we we believe that's important because
an auto like that
could take away from the the work that
we need to do
we'd rather provide the information in a
raw format so that people can do that
work
if i heard you right you aren't going to
pursue an independent civil rights audit
but you are going to continue to release
data and to consult with civil rights
groups i i'd welcome a more thorough
answer as to
in which way having an independent
outside audit would actually harm
your transparency efforts i i don't i
don't mean it would harm it
um i mean that we we want to provide
enough information so that people can do
this work independently of us
um on their own timelines and that's
where we need to make our transparency
report more robust and as i said we have
regular conversations
with these groups and take feedback
regularly
you do mr dorsey have policies against
deep fakes or manipulated media against
covet 19 misinformation against
things that violate civic integrity but
you don't have a standalone
climate change misinformation policy why
not
well misleading information as you are
aware is a
is a large problem it's hard to define
it
completely and cohesively we wanted to
scope our approach to start
to focus on the highest severity of harm
we focused on three areas manipulated
media which you mentioned
civic integrity around the election
specifically
in public health specifically around
covet
you know we want to make sure that our
resources that we have
have the greatest impact on where we
believed
the greatest severity of harm is going
to be um
our policies are living documents they
will evolve we will add to them
but we thought it important that we
focus our energies
and prioritize the work as much as we
could
well mr dorsey i'll close with this i
just i i cannot think of
a greater harm um than climate change
which is transforming literally our
planet and causing harm to our entire
world
i think we're experiencing significant
harm as we speak i recognize
the pandemic and misinformation about
covert 19
manipulated media also cause harm but
i'd urge you to reconsider that because
helping uh to disseminate climate
denialism in my view
further facilitates and accelerates one
of the greatest existential threats to
our world
so and thank you to both of our
witnesses thank you
sinners
thank you mr chair and mr zuckerberg
and mr dorsey thank you both for being
here
with us today virtually uh and for your
commitment to constantly
improving the way your platforms are
serving
people across the country there has been
a lot of talk today
many of us have been listening from our
offices or
online um about the censorship of
ideas and news on your platforms and
these are the things
that have been at the forefront of
americans minds in the lead-up to
the election as well as the week since
our 2020 general election and
you know the people that that i hear
from of course
believe that conservatives were
wrongfully being silenced
while those on the left that were given
basically free reign
of your platforms and one of the points
of contention that is often brought up
is that you do recruit heavily from
california which leads to your employee
base skewing quite heavily
to the left so my first question
is for both of you do you have concerns
about your ability to monitor
disinformation on both sides of the
political aisle
equally given that the majority of your
employees typically do lean towards the
more progressive side
and again to both of you have you taken
any steps then
at all to make your employee base more
representative of the country as a whole
when it comes to
political affiliation and mr zuckerberg
if we could start with you please
thank you senator i think this is uh
those are both really important topics
in terms of assessing what is
misinformation i think it's
uh important that we don't
become the deciders on everything that
is true or false ourselves which is why
we've tried to build a program of
independent fact checkers that we can
work with on this
and those fact checkers are accredited
not by us
but by the the independent pointer
institute for for journalism as part of
the international
uh fact-checking network and it
uh includes fact-checkers that i think
span
the political spectrum as well as um i
think the majority of them
who who would call themselves apolitical
so
we've tried to address the the issue of
um
of making sure that there isn't a bias
in our actions by
actually having us not be the deciders
on that type of content
um ourselves and to your second question
about
taking steps to diversify the the
employee base
um we we we
this is a a sensitive area in that i
don't think it would be appropriate for
us to
ask people on the way in as they were
interviewing what their political
affiliation is which of course makes it
hard to know
um what the actual uh breakdown of the
the company is on this but
one of the areas where i'm more
optimistic over time
is i think we're going to see more
people working remotely around the
country and also around the world which
will mean
that fewer people a smaller percent of
our employees will have to
come to um you know the the cities and
areas like the bay area where our
headquarters is um and we'll be able to
employ an increasing number of people
across
um all the different geographies in the
country
very good thank you and mr dorsey
first and foremost the most important
thing is that we we built systems
and frameworks independent of any one
particular
employee or individual our company and
inclusive and included in that system
are checkpoints
checkpoints to make sure that we are
removing any bias that we find
checkpoints to do qa and monitoring
of all the decisions that we make having
an appeals process which is an external
checkpoint
on whether we made the correct uh
enforcement action or not
so we want to build something that's
independent of the people that we hire
and that is our focus building a system
second
like mark i'm really excited that
we are at a stage where we can
decentralize
our company even more um that we do not
need people
to move to san francisco that we can
hire people all over the country they
can stay
where they want to be whether wherever
they feel most created and that's not
just
in this country it's around the world
and i think the tools
are in a state where we can do that more
easily
we've obviously been forced to do it uh
with covid
um and i don't think it's a state that
we will
return from with the days of having one
centralized
massive corporate headquarters in any
one particular city
are certainly over for us at least and i
think many other entrepreneurs starting
companies today
yeah very good i really appreciate that
and and i think that covetous taught us
all a very
important lesson and for those to be
able to work remotely i think you will
find greater diversity
in thought which is very important i
think for the types of platforms
that you both represent now i'd like to
move on to an entirely different topic
and since i began my career here in the
senate i have been committed to
of course protecting those who need it
most and and folks are
our children are the most in need and
it's our job as lawmakers
to respond to the ongoing threats
against them and
social media has created a whole new
world for
for all of us and it can help us share
that information
and resources with the public about
human trafficking uh and child
exploitation and it can also
help us keep track of sexual predators
and ensure our children are safe
from those known threats and in fact
i've been working
on legislation that would help update
what information
sexual predators have to provide about
their
online identities and as we all know
however
uh social media can also be incredibly
harmful uh child sexual abuse material
csam
is present on nearly every single
social media platform that exists and
in such polarized times i am grateful
that it is this subject that
we do find it doesn't matter if you're
on the left or the right we can come
together
to find solutions uh for this issue and
mr zuckerberg i know that you and i
touched upon this briefly last week when
we spoke over the phone
and i do hope mr dorsey that you also
share mr zuckerberg's commitment
to fighting these types of issues on
your platforms
um so just very briefly here um as i'm
running out of time
but mr zuckerberg i do understand that
facebook is planning to outfit
outfit facebook messenger with
end-to-end encryption
and how do you hope to prevent the
dissemination of
child sexual abuse material if neither
law enforcement nor you can access
that messenger data is there some sort
of apparatus that you will have in
in place that can help law enforcement
with those situations
and then um mr dorsey will go to you
next as well
senator thank you for this
i think you are you're right on uh
on every count and what you just said
both that uh
child sexual exploitation is is one of
the
gravest threats that we focus the most
on
and it is also an area that
will face new challenges as we move to
um intend encryption
across our messaging systems
of course the reason why we're moving to
encryption
um is because people want greater
privacy and security
um in in their messaging systems and um
over time are choosing systems that can
provide them more privacy and security
and
that's something that i think it makes
sense for us to offer i think encryption
broadly is good but it is going to mean
that we're going to need to find and
develop some new tactics
um a lot of what we have found around
the best ways to identify bad actors on
our system
is not actually by looking at the
specific content itself
uh but by looking at patterns of
activity and where is it
that a group or a person is not behaving
in the way that a normal person would
um so you can flag and review that um
and
we've grown increasingly sophisticated
at that that that goes across the
foreign interference prevention work
that we do
and it also will be a factor here and
i'd be happy to follow up in more detail
on
what we have planned but uh overall i
would say this is something that we're
very focused on and i
i agree with your concern okay thank you
very much and and mr dorsey
you as well um so those that are on
twitter making sure that
uh law enforcement would have access if
at all possible
um you know if you could give me an
overview of that please
child expectation is absolutely terrible
and we don't tolerate it on our service
at all um we regularly work with law
enforcement um to address anything that
we see
include inclusive of the the patterns
that mark has mentioned
uh the majority of twitter is public um
so we don't have as much activity
in private channels um so it's a
different uh different approach but
um it's still you know we still see the
same activity and we
it's uh one of our highest priorities in
terms of severity harm
thank you both very much for being
accessible to us today i truly
appreciate your input mr chairman thank
you thank you
ms zuckerberg i really want to
appreciate what facebook has done in the
area of
sexual exploitation of children y'all
have done a very good job of trying to
to help law enforcement in that area
senator hirono
mr chairman zuckerberg for the second
time in three weeks
you've been called before the senate
committee so my republican colleagues
can
beat you up over claims that your
platforms are supposedly biased against
conservatives
the fact of the matter is that these
allegations are completely baseless
everyone who has systematically looked
at the content of social
media from media matters to the cato
institute to former republican senator
john kyle has found absolutely no
evidence
of anti-conservative bias and data from
crowd tangle show that far right content
from the likes of fox news ben shapiro
david bongino dominates the daily top
10 most engaged pages
on facebook so all of these allegations
about the fact that
you hire or all of your employees are
left of center
is a relevant of nothing certainly not
relevant of some sort of
anti-conservative bias in terms of your
moderation so the way i see it this
hearing is a transparent effort
by my republican colleagues to work the
refs
and unfortunately in my view it is
working
two weeks ago the washington post
reported that facebook
has bent over backwards to avoid claims
that it was biased against conservatives
and
it removed a strike against donald trump
jr's instagram
account that would have penalized him as
a repeat offender
apparently one of several strikes
removed from the accounts of trump
family members pro trump's super pac
american first action was allowed to
post
material rated false by facebook's third
party fact checkers
without penalty and these are just a few
examples
and they are nothing new in 2019
facebook
included breitbart a website described
by its co-founder as a platform
for the alt-right as one of its trusted
news sources early in 2019 facebook
selected
the daily caller another site with white
nationalist
ties to be one of his third party fact
checkers
and the wall street journal has reported
how joel kaplan former
deputy chief of staff to george w bush
stopped
changes designed to make facebook's
algorithms
less divisive because the changes would
have disproportionately
affected conservative users and
publishers according to kaplan
so mr zuckerberg you founded facebook
a company with a market capitalization
of approximately
80 billion dollars and you control a
majority share
of the company's voting stock and mr
exactly where i
i'm really wondering at one point at
what point you will stop giving
in to basis claims of anti-conservative
bias and start exercising
your control over facebook to stop
driving division and actually support
you
build community and bring the world
closer together and quote
as you claim is facebook's mission my
questions to both of you
a recent harvard study found that
president trump
was the single biggest source of voter
related
and misinformation and the run-up to the
presidential election
since the election president trump has
only continued the lies on twitter and
facebook
also claiming that he won re-election
and that the election is being stolen
from him
but the true truth is jobin won the
election as major news
networks and the associated press have
confirmed
in response to president trump's lies
you have at most
added a warning label while still
allowing the president's misinformation
to remain
online in response to questions from
senator feinstein
we defended the labels claiming they
point people to a broader conversation
around the election i have serious
questions about the effectiveness of
these labels
particularly since president trump and
his allies continue to spread their
lives
for both of you what evidence do you
have that these labels are effective
in addressing president trump's lives
response please so um
and i think uh mark mentioned this
earlier as well we are doing a
retrospective
on the effectiveness of all of our
actions
through the election we believe the
labels
point to as you said a broader
conversation
that people can see what's happening
with the election and with the results
we don't want to put ourselves in a
position of calling
an election that is not our job so we're
pointing to
um sources and pillars that have
traditionally done this
in the past and that is that is the
intention of the policy that's the
intention
of the labeling system
mr zuckerberg senator
we view the additional context that we
put on posts as
part of an overall response and effort
to make sure that people have
reliable information about
about the election so we don't expect
that it's just going to be when people
are seeing a post that
maybe casting doubt on a on a legitimate
form of voting
or may have misinformation that we can
correct and help people
understand how they could really vote
for example so that's why we put the
voter information center
uh prominently on the top of facebook
and instagram
for months leading up to the election um
and kept it
up afterwards so people can see uh
reporting on on the results
as i mentioned in my my opening
statement 140 million americans
visited that um i think this was the
largest voting information campaign
um in the history of our country so i
think when taken together
um these actions um are
were quite strong of an effort uh to
to communicate accurate and reliable
information to people at the times when
they when they needed it
about how they could vote in the
election encouraging them to vote
having confidence in the election system
knowing who
and and when the election had been
called
it's just part of an overall system my
time is uh
and so all of the information the actual
information voter information you
provide
that is good but we're talking about all
of these misinformation
and actually our lies that are put out
by the president and you have these
labels
and i really have questions as to
whether or not this kind of labeling
and i'm glad that at least mr dorsey is
uh determining whether these labels do
anything
to actually create a larger
framework for discussion i really
seriously consider you know doubt
whether that is actually happening
uh since i'm running out of time i just
wanted to get to
you know um donald trump as president
you consider
him newsworthy so a lot of his posts get
on whether they have contained
misinformation especially on whether
whether he won the election
and covet you name it the the fraudulent
elections that he alleges etc but
i wonder what what are both of you
prepared to do regarding donald
trump's use of your platforms
after he stops being president will he
still be deemed
newsworthy and will he still get to use
your platform to spread
his misinformation
senator let me clarify my last answer
we are also having academics study the
the effective
um of all of our election measures and
they'll be publishing those results
publicly
in terms of president trump and
and moving forward um there are
a small number of policies where we
have exceptions for politicians under
the principle that people should
be able to hear what their elected
officials are are saying and candidates
for office
but by and large the vast majority of
our policies have no newsworthiness or
political exception
so if if the president or anyone else is
spreading hate speech or inciting
violence
um or posting content that delegitimizes
the election or valid forms of voting
um those will receive the same treatment
as anyone else saying those things
and that will continue to be the case
remains to be seen mr dorsey so we do
have a policy
around public interest where for global
leaders
we do make exceptions in terms of
whether if a if a tweet violates our
terms of service
we leave it up but we leave it up behind
in interstitial
and people are not not allowed to share
that
more broadly so a lot of the sharing is
disabled with the exception of
quoting it so that you can add your own
conversation on top of it
so if an account suddenly uh becomes uh
is not a world leader anymore that
particular policy goes away
so i i am running out of time but you
know i have
mr chairman i'd like to enter into the
record
a number of studies uh particularly a
november
first 2020 article in the washington
post titled trump allies largely
unconstrained by facebook's rules
against repeated falsehoods
cement pre-election dominance a may 26
2020 article in the wall street journal
titled facebook executive shutdown
efforts to make the sideless
divisive three studies from media
matters finding no anti-conservative
bias
on facebook and an article by dr
francesca tripode
titled no big tech isn't silencing
conservatism i would like to enter
these items into the record without
objection senator kennedy
thank you mr chairman
uh gentlemen
each of you has founded
an extraordinarily successful company
and they're both american companies
and i think i would be remiss if i
didn't say
congratulations i'm very proud of the
fact
that it was american ingenuity
uh that did this
i think we can also both agree that both
twitter
and facebook have enormous
power as a result of your success
um you're not country you're not
companies your countries
at least in terms of power
i want to i want to test a point of view
here i'm not sure
i subscribe to it but i want to get your
thoughts
on it mr dorsey
do you believe everything you read
no why not
i think it's healthy to have skepticism
about everything and have a mindset of
verifying it and using as much
information as possible to do so
do you have somebody on your staff
who protects you from reading things
that they think you shouldn't
no uh mr zuckerberg
do you believe everything you read
no senator why not
uh because a lot of things are
incomplete or
incorrect so you
exercise your own judgment
do you have somebody on your staff whose
job is to
filter things that they think you should
not be reading
senator not
not externally although i would hope
that the teams that i work with
internally do their best to
make sure that the information that
they're presenting me with are always
accurate okay
here is a point of view i'm not sure i
subscribe to it
but it is a legitimate point of view i
think and i'd like to know your thoughts
on it
you have both and this is directed to
each of you
you have both democrats and republicans
upset with you the democrats are upset
with you
this point of view holds
because they want you to publish i'm not
using that
word as a as a term of uh of art or
science here
with any special meanings the democrats
want you to
publish stuff on your platforms that
they agree with but they don't want you
to publish stuff
that they disagree with and this point
of view also holds
that the republicans are upset with you
because they want you
to publish things on your platforms that
they agree with but they
don't want you to publish stuff on your
platforms that they disagree with
what if we had a rule
what if what if your companies had a
rule
this is a question not a suggestion
what if your companies had a rule that
said okay
people aren't morons
i i would like to treat people as they
treat me
um that is that
i can read what i want to read and
exercise my own good judgment
about whether i choose to believe it
so here's the rule we're adopting
if you go on twitter or facebook
you can't bully people
you can't threaten people
maybe this is a subset of both of those
but
you can't commit a crime with your words
and you can't incite violence
but other than that you can print any
damn thing you want to
and we'll let our users judge
give me your thoughts on that
those are generally the rules we have i
mean our focus on these policies
no no you don't mr doris excuse me for
interrupting but
but you're censoring right and left
trying to make both sides happen
and you're making neither side happy
no that that's not the intention the
intention is i know it's not the
attention but it's
the intention but it's the result
i i can see why you might say that and
why you might perceive that
and that's why we you know we do think
it's important that we add more
transparency to how we
moderate content that we give more
control to individuals
to moderate their own content and focus
on algorithms but
a lot of our policies are focused on
making sure that people feel
that they can express themselves in the
first place and not driven away
everything you mentioned about bullying
about harassment around
illegal content or violence and
statement to violence
that is what our policies are and that
is i know and excuse me for interrupting
but my time's limited because and i want
to hear from mr zuckerberg
but you're not just doing that you're
you've started to censor content
why not have both mr biden and mr trump
able to say whatever they want to on
your platform
mr sucker so long as they don't threaten
bully
and cite violence commit a crime i'm not
justifying
the use of either twitter or facebook to
to
uh to hurt the rohingyas
mr zuckerberg what are your thoughts on
my suggestion
get out of the censorship business other
than
the exceptions i talked about
senator in principle i agree with what
you are
saying although i think that there are
more categories of harm
than just the ones that you've mentioned
so
but i think the basic principle behind
what you're saying is
a a definition of free expression that
says that people should be able to
share their opinions broadly
except if it's going to cause imminent
or irreparable harm to another person
which now even the most ardent first
amendment
supporters you know agree
that you shouldn't be able to yell fire
in a crowded theater
if there's not actually a fire right
because that could put people in the
risk of imminent harm so you mentioned
terrorism you mentioned child
exploitation and bullying as forms of
harm and
i think a lot of the debate is around
what are other forms of harm
for example we're in the middle of a
pandemic
and we've assessed that misinformation
about covid
and treatments uh that that could put
people in
additional risk of getting the disease
or not seeking the right treatment if
they have it
that those are also things that could
cause imminent harm
um we've taken the position that mr
zuckerberg let me interrupt you and i
really do apologize uh but i'm i'm gonna
be cut off in a second and appropriately
so
i'm not saying you're wrong by doing
what you just described
but that makes you a publisher
and uh that that uh that
creates problems with section 230.
and i just think it one point of view is
that at some point
we we've got to trust people to use
their own good judgment
to decide what they choose to believe
and not believe
and not not not try to uh assume that
we're smart and they're stupid
and that we can we can discern
believable information and information
that shouldn't be believed but everybody
else is too stupid to do it
okay i'm done thank you mr chairman i
think you put your finger on a
really maybe the central issue senator
kennedy is how do we
let people make up their own minds
without what they're saying
creating violence or threats to others
very complicated endeavor uh
senator booker
chairman can you hear me chairman
yes and to our witnesses we have two
more senators and we'll be done and i
appreciate your patience
senator booker i i appreciate that uh mr
chairman and i
appreciate listening to this to this
hearing um i really want to bring uh
just focus back to what i think is
why we're here which is the 2020
election and
i've been saying in this committee for
many months now
about the tragic consequences of us
normalizing things that should express
considerable outrage there's not a
person on this committee on either side
that doesn't know who the next president
united states will be
president-elect joe biden and kamal
harris uh
will be the president and vice president
united states come january 20th but
what is going on right now is dangerous
and it is a threat to our democracy
for the first time in american history
we are seeing a sitting president united
states
make wild and baseless accusations
that undermine the democratic process
that don't just delegitimize it what the
president united states is doing
is trying to thwart our democracy as we
speak donald trump is waging
an all-out war on the truth and our
democratic systems
and one of his weapons of choice in this
disinformation war
is social media and specifically uh the
two gentlemen here
uh their platforms twitter and facebook
uh you have the tools to prevent him
from weaponizing these platforms
to degrade our democracy and our
democratic institutions and to cause
such damage
that even after january 20th it could be
one of the first times
that millions of americans think can
believe
that this election uh was uh was basil
baselessly being charged by donald trump
and so let's be clear on what's happened
donald trump's
shameful uh and shameless lies that are
persisting about voter fraud
and the outcome of this election were
some of the most engaged
content on social media in the days
after the election
by one measure during the week after the
election his posts on facebook
made up all every single one
of the top most top 10 most engaged
posts
in the united states and 22 out of 25
of the top most engaged posts in our
country
and his number one post the top of them
all
was a false declaration of victory
on twitter his false uh his his tweet on
falsely claiming victory
was viewed by millions of users this
was and is not just a disinformation
campaign by the president united states
but literally the most powerful person
in our country
doing an all-out assault on the
constitutional ideal of a democracy
that he was sworn to protect so let's
take a step back
because i i think this would be
bipartisan if we looked at what was
happening in another country
if we saw and i'm on the foreign
relations committee and i know
how we come together on issues like this
if a strong leader
strong man leader of a democracy had
denied his loss
in an election in a democratic election
made consistent and constant baseless
claims about
fraud if he fired military leaders while
his foreign minister
talked about a smooth transition of the
defeated leaders next term
even potentially ingest any government
looking at this situation including
ours uh would be putting out statements
urging calm
and calling for the peaceful transition
of power for the rule of law for the
honoring
of democratic norms and traditions and
so we're seeing concrete consequences
right now of president trump's rhetoric
we are actually in the midst of the
fourth largest
mass casualty event in american history
this is not just something that should
not be treated with calm and normalcy
but we all people who believe in this
country should be standing up and
talking about
the consequences we have his political
appointee the general service
administrator refusing to designate joe
biden as president-elect and provide
the transition team the resources
mandated by federal
law it was not that long ago that the
911 commission
said that one of the things that
undermined our ability to meet the
terroristic threats to our country
happened because of a transition that
was undermined or excuse me the
transition that did not happen in the
normal course
president trump's actions since election
day should shock
all of us all of us who care about the
welfare of our democracy
who care about our norms and i hope the
platforms
here can maintain the highest levels of
vigilance
and so to the gentleman before us today
i'd like to ask specifically
um have you taken any steps to modify
your platform's algorithms
to ensure that blatantly false election
dis
information posted by election officials
and specifically the most powerful
person in the united states donald trump
isn't amplify
that his posts that might get a lot of
interactions
uh uh that are dead wrong don't somehow
get boosted by your algorithms
if you could both respond to that as
quickly as possible
senator i'll go first and and i share
your concern on this and i think it's
unfortunate that we had to
uh put in place a policy around
premature or false declarations of
victory but
um but we had to do that and we we
anticipated this back in september when
we put the policy in place and a lot of
what we're trying to do is help
distribute reliable information which we
attach
both to um posts on the topic by
um by president trump or
um any of the other candidates or or
elected officials who are talking on the
subject
but more importantly we put uh that
reliable information including about
election results
at the top of facebook and instagram
for everyone to see and that supersedes
um
you know what with the algorithm or what
news feed
i appreciate that i i just like to get
jax this is information i know
jack if you want to just respond on the
algorithm excuse mr dorsey
do you want to respond about the
algorithms too do you have
uh specific measures that you're taking
to prevent
your algorithms from boosting uh false
content
yes sir so many of the labels um did
change
how the algorithms amplify content
and then uh you know uh president trump
right now is spreading dangerous
misinformation
about our electoral process that's going
on right now
uh and maybe if you guys uh the
gentleman would
just cogently through this process this
ongoing process right now
are there steps you will be taking that
that you have not already delineated
uh as we are going into what could be
very dangerous waters
unprecedented waters in this country is
there any additional steps that you will
be taking
uh right now in the coming days or weeks
uh
to stop the further amplification and
undermining
of our of our of our democracy we are
heading potentially
depending upon the behavior of a
president who's shown himself to be
erratic
uh uh or their steps you were prepared
to take
uh in in the coming days and weeks to
address uh this misinformation that we
are seeing is coming in their
unrelenting manner
this is unfortunately an eventuality
that we
that we planned for um we've taken a
number of steps
um not just including the fact-checking
program that we've set up broadly
but we stopped recommending all civic
and political groups as an example
because of risk of misinformation or or
harm growing there we've temporarily
paused all political ads because of a
risk of
potential abuse or um inflaming
tension or or potential unrest or
violence
um and there are a number of other steps
that we've taken like this as well
um that we've done in other countries
when there are risks of civil unrest
um and that we've shown have worked so
i'd be happy to follow up
in detail on all of the steps that we're
taking there oh
thank you your team has been it's been
helpful um mr dorsey any new steps that
you want to give me and
and i'm now treading on the indulgence
of the chairman if you could be really
cogent i need new steps
um we're we're going to continue to
remain diligent around uh our
enforcement of civilian integrity i
think it's really important that we
that we stay agile and that we learn so
we need to learn about
like the effectiveness of this work and
and how to carry it forward
right and and the the chairman would
indulge me in one more
uh sort of question uh to mr zuckerberg
i was really pleased um uh that
the group stopped the steal which was a
group formed on facebook with
disinformation
trying to delegitimize the election uh i
was grateful that you all
uh suspended that account uh after 24
hours
but i'm concerned about what lessons
you've learned because clearly
outside groups like the center for
countering digital hate
flagged that group's posts uh containing
uh calls to violence
uh hours before facebook did and i'm
wondering
what what you all have learned about
speed uh there's an old
saying that a lie can travel halfway
around the world while the truth is
still putting its pants
on uh what does facebook really factor
in
uh in terms of uh speed and trying to
combat
surges of disinformation about this
group and
and and maybe another example an
additional sort of
addendum to that question mr zuckerberg
um you know mr bannon twitter for
example
permanently suspended mr bannon's
twitter account uh it suspended his
show's twitter account
uh after he made horrendous steps about
acts of violence
against dr fauci and and fbi director
ray
um but you but not only uh
i guess i'm just simply asking why would
uh facebook not take
uh the similar uh steps in similar stand
so
mr zuckerberg very cogently could you
talk about that speed
issue and then i when these when your
platforms diverge
uh i'm really wondering why one platform
in twitter saw that as a standard to
remove but you all
uh have left uh uh did not follow in
that decision
thanks senator i'm happy to address both
of those on speed
you're certainly right that that's
important uh and
part of what we focus on
is figuring out which uh which types of
messages or things are going to go viral
quickest um because you
it's not just about trying to get to
everything within
you know in five hours for example
it's actually much more important to get
to the harms that are going viral
quickly
within an hour even if some things that
are probably not going to get much
distribution at all
might be de-prioritized for a little bit
longer so i think making sure that
we stay on top of what are the hashtags
what are the groups
what are the messages who are the uh bad
actors who are trying to spread this
content
and as we see the threat evolving um we
are typically able to
uh evolve and move faster as well um so
we're
very focused on that thank you thank you
how much uh
anything you just i just want to give
you an amen
uh uh uh
i i will the second part of that
question i'd love to get on the record
but i just want to say to you
you mentioned earlier i know you said
that chairman graham
will be chairman again but i think he
really said something really important
earlier about the effects of social
media platforms on our kids uh
university i think
outside many studies at the university
of pittsburgh who said that kids are on
social media
have about twice the the rates of eating
disorders and image concerns
i just would really say and i know that
a two gentleman there would
would welcome the opportunity to come
and discuss that perhaps with other
experts
but there's something really going on in
terms of the self-esteem well-being
and even flourishing of our children who
are deeply affected by these platforms
whether you want to use
a technical term like addiction or not
it it there's there's enough evidence
that these platforms uh and children's
engagement on them
is causing uh heightened levels of a
sort of a deleterious effect on
on their well-being and i'd love uh it
if we could do uh such a hearing uh
sometime soon we will follow up into the
every patient senator blackburn
thank you mr chairman last but certainly
not least that is correct and i
appreciate that and um even though my
colleague from new jersey went
twice his time i i am going to
uh these are the senate minutes yeah yes
they're senate minutes
uh i will agree with
my colleagues who have talked about the
impact on children
the distribution of information that
damages women
and children that leads to violence
against women and children
human trafficking the utilization of
these platforms by pedophiles
this is something that we are going to
continue to work on when i was in the
house we passed legislation to put more
tools
in the hands of local law enforcement to
fight this but
you all at these social media platforms
are going to have to do
your part to work with us on this to
protect our children
i will also say that we're keeping an
eye
and with each of you yesterday i talked
about your
financial component square uh therefore
mr dorsey in
libra with mr zuckerberg and the
application
of these components to
your sites we're talking about 2020
elections but we're also looking ahead
to how we clean up
some of what transpired in the 20
and before the 2022 elections
i think it's fair to say too that you
all probably
are now fully aware that there's great
frustration
with americans and with this committee
with the way you act
invincible the way your employees act as
if you're the invincible gods of the
silicon valley
facebook and twitter don't get to be the
last word
in what counts as real news in this
country even though you're beginning to
conduct yourself
as news publishers and distributors
my colleagues and i have asked you all
repeatedly through the years for greater
transparency and to
accept responsibility you've chosen to
do neither
so it is going to be up to us to change
existing law
and to hold you to account on behalf
of the american people uh
section 230 the reforms uh
that we're going to put in place will
take away this liability shield that
you've turned into an
opaque wall that you and your content
moderators whether they're algorithmic
or human beings or a combination
are hiding behind and the online freedom
and viewpoint diversity act i thank
chairman graham and chairman wicker for
working with me on this this is set up
for a markup
in this committee on thursday and mr
zuckerberg you were stating earlier
that we needed to put some definition in
place we're going to do that
we're going to take away nebulous
language and we're going to be
specific unlawful inciting personal harm
inciting terrorism we're going to do
that
and clear that up for you mr zuckerberg
facebook is more like a government than
a traditional company
is a statement that you have made
there's a lot of power
in that for you so yes or no
on a couple of questions here does
facebook routinely
censor a user's account at the behest
of a foreign government yes or no
um senator i'm
i'm not sure if there's anything in
particular you're referring to but in
general we
well there is something in particular
that i'm
uh referring to and i'll answer it yes
you've done that you have 60 million
users in vietnam
of course this is a communist regime
under the orders of the vietnamese
government did facebook shut down and
banned the account
of the vietnamese dissident because he
criticized the governor's government's
land policy yes or no
um so i'm not familiar with all the
details of that but i believe
that we uh that we may have done that
and that in general
we try to follow the local law and you
kept him off for three months uh in
turkey does facebook have an
anti-blasphemy policy where it will take
down photos
of the prophet muhammad if the turkish
government
orders it to do so
senator again we don't have a policy
against that
but the answer is we do follow
well we we follow local laws
the answer is yes in russia under
pressure from the russian government did
facebook take down a post
advertising the rally in support of the
dissident
alexei navali
the answer is yes i'll help you with
that do you believe it's facebook's duty
to comply
with state sponsored censorship so it
can keep
operating doing business and selling ads
in that country
senator in general we try to comply with
the laws
in every country where we operate and do
business
okay and i think that uh you prioritize
profit
over principle when you look at these
countries and also in communist china
which they have banned
their citizens from you uh you can't
operate there um and
in china twitter you have an opponent
there you've got a knock
off weibo that is a chinese communist
party
owned company but your companies even
though they're banned there you're still
trying to do business in those countries
mr dorsey does twitter do business with
huawei
um i don't i don't believe so but we can
follow up
oh i can answer it for you sir uh
you helped launch huawei's mape 3
pro 5g and it is featured on twitter's
marketing page website
uh how about alibaba you do uh
business with jack ma's company with
their links to the chinese communist
party
if if by business you mean allowing
people to advertise on a property
your answer is yes mr zuckerberg are you
aware that last year china's top
internet regulator
agreed to spend over eight hundred
thousand dollars for the communist
mouthpiece the people's daily and they
did this
so that they could advertise and promote
china
to the american people on facebook
the point of all of this and the answer
to that mr
zuckerberg whether you're aware or not
is you probably
are and you know that what they're doing
is gaining access to this market this is
why we're going to keep a real close
watch
over what you all are doing with libra
and what you are
doing uh with with uh
square because we see what has happened
it's important for us to protect people
and to protect human
rights and your election
let me move to election content
and that monitoring
because we do have concerns about some
of the things that happened there
mr zuckerberg let me ask you this have
you heard of the trump
accountability project
senator i'm not familiar with that okay
that is a project that
is an attempt to blacklist americans who
have served
in the trump
she's doing her job